a paper that was recently published
about
uh frog calls and uh i
i worked on frogs as you were well aware
um
and uh it is true that in the northern
hemisphere
uh the spring equinox is a moment around
which many people are beginning to hear
a lot of frog calls um so there are you
know there are more than seven thousand
species of frogs worldwide
um and there are a lot of ways that
frogs um hook up
a lot of ways for frogs to meet their
mating partners um
actually and they do hook up they they
do hook up a very rare frog that has
an extended relationship um and
here's zach um you can just show my
screen for a moment i just i went back
into one of the lectures i've given on
amphibians over the year
this is various um uh frog
reproductive positions uh it's called
emplexus and uh
and it's the male in in gray and the
female in
in white and they just uh they don't
have what's called an intermittent organ
they don't have a penis or equivalent
and so they just have to touch cloacas
and they figure out a lot of ways to do
it so that's uh
that's kind of a hookup and sometimes he
does hook his his
fingers or his toes around around the
female and um and sometimes amplexes can
last for
months now wait a second did you just
say
that no frogs have a penis
yes however you see where i'm going with
that i do you don't go go for it
well i was just going to say isn't there
at least
one clay maybe it's even just one
species that i think we have locally
here am i wrong
it's the most basal clade of extant
frogs escape a day
with the type genius basil escapus it is
a
it is the common name is tailed frogs
and they are yes here in the pacific
northwest and endemic the pacific
northwest
and they um it is they're called the
tailed frogs it's a tail
it's it's the it's the remnant of of a
tail
it is the remnant of a tail that
functions as an intermittent organ
i didn't look i don't remember for sure
but i think so yes okay
but i like boy you know i'm here talking
about frogs if i know everything about
frogs remember there's over seven
thousand species i don't know all of
them
i think escape is true i may still be
the only species that may there may be
more now
um i don't i think it may be used as
intermittent organ
but it's not a very good one okay how
about that so we are now engaged in
escapism
i would say absolutely um but it is
interesting
that it is basal because this is a
little bit like
the familiar example that people will
know is
the egg-laying mammals the monotremes
are basil to the mammal tree so the
point is platypus
and the echidnas so people will be
familiar with a characteristic
that was part of the early radiation of
some
clade that persists but was lost quickly
and therefore you only have the
the few species left or in this case
escapus maybe it's one
uh one species but anyway yes so the
exception that uh i wouldn't say proves
the rule in this case but
it helps to demonstrate it right um
so lots and lots of ways for frogs to
get it on
and lots you know actually the frogs
that i've worked on
um sometimes give tremendous parental
care to their kids they you know have
relationship
relation relationships with their
offspring um but almost no temperate
species do temperate species
temperate species referring to the
temperate zones where
most viewers probably are as opposed to
the tropics or the or the polar regions
the arctic and antarctic and um
what to the degree that people are in
the northern temperate zone right now
and it's spring
now as of today and they're hearing
these um
choruses of frogs from local ponds those
are what are called explosive breeding
assemblages
and don't worry it's not dangerous i
have yet to find an actual frog
exploding although it could be
interesting i'd feel sorry for the frog
but that's not actually
um what it refers to it's these frogs
who have been depending
on where they are and what species um
hiding out
sometimes buried underground literally
frozen solid for the winter in order to
survive the winter like lots of crazy
adaptations that frogs use to get
through a harsh
northern temperate winter they are now
convening in one place that is um that
is a good site for them to breed in and
these sites tend to be reproductively
limiting for them and so you get lots of
speed often you get lots of species in
one place
and they show up in these um explosively
breeding assemblages explosive i think
really just referring to the fact that
like well last week there was no one
there and suddenly
my god it's so loud i can barely hear
myself think it's an explosion of
of frogs yeah so so question for you
um i can think of two reasons that you
might have
repeated evolutions of explosive
breeding in frogs and i'm wondering is
there
is one of maybe there's an explanation i
haven't thought of but
do we know why this evolves repeatedly
so i would so my my explanations would
be that
one it could be uh the ephemeral nature
of the opportunity
that's probably so to the extent that a
pond uh
shows up and is available for a brief
time there might be an optimal moment
to breed in it and all of the frogs
would have some detector that would tell
them when that optimal moment is
i'm doubtful of this because not all of
the pawns will be ephemeral not all the
pons are ephemeral however
the more in the temperate zone you are
the more important
the seasonal change will be to getting
it getting it right in terms of like
this is the moment when you're laying
eggs because this is the amount of time
your eggs are going to take to mature
into tadpoles and that your tadpoles
will take to metamorphose into frogs
and those frogs have to be of a certain
size and gained a certain number of
resources before the next winter comes
or else they're more likely to die
okay and watch this if the pond isn't
ephemeral it is much more likely to have
fish in it and if it has fish in it it's
not so great for frogs there are frogs
that get along with fish to an extent
but to
when we typically find one of these
ponds that has just you know thousands
of frogs in it it tends to be uh
fishless
so it's pre so um oh i thought i thought
you were going to go to
um to some degree concentrating all at
once um
in upon you know if if sites without
fish
are absent yeah then it could be a form
of predator satiation that was going to
be my other hypothesis
was that the explosive breeding so the
way predator satiation works for
those of you who haven't run into the
concept
you have let's say you've got frogs and
their predators
the population of predators is small
when there are no frogs available to the
extent that those are
specialists um and then
if all the frogs breed at once then the
population of predators doesn't
have an opportunity to rise if all of
the frogs bred in sequence so they were
available throughout the year let's say
that
they were distributed across the year
then the
egg predators would get more and more
common or even the frog predators would
get more and more common and they would
rise to carrying capacity whereas
if there aren't any frogs available or
eggs available
then the population of the predators
drops quite low
and then when there is suddenly a huge
abundance of frogs those small number of
predators
eat their fill and are done and the
population of their population doesn't
have a chance to rise to absorb all of
the
the bounty that is available so by
concentrating it in time they avoid a
lot of the predation that they would
otherwise face
i'm guessing that must be the primary
explanation for explosive breeding in
frogs
it's uh i would say that that goes in
concert with and it will be hard to
separate from
uh the fact that in much of the northern
southern temperate zone two there's just
less of it um the northern temperate
zone the winters
winters are very hard on amphibians in
particular and you know all
all herps all all reptiles and
amphibians in part because they're not
endothermic and so
you know they have to be collecting
their heat from external
um from from the environment and it's
hard to do when it's negative 20 out
right um and so they um they have a
relatively short period every year
when they can actually you know profit
evolutionarily when they can make a
living for themselves and breed and all
of this and so
there are depending on species either
photo period cues or temperature cues
there are cues that prompt them to
emerge
to you know return if they were
migrating you know whatever it is to
show up
and that that because it is
a short period of time um having a fair
level of precision on when the breeding
season is is also
important so i think those two things go
hand in hand obviously
cool well that makes sense um and so yes
we do hear we actually hear uh
frogs sounds like they're ringing in our
uh backyard yeah i haven't i haven't
looked at we just started to hear them
and i haven't actually looked up
what they are yet although it should be
obvious there's just not that many
species of frogs here
um and we don't have a pond so i'm not
sure we have some creeks running through
um below our primary yeah um
okay so there is an um
atlantic article out this month uh
called this
sac if you would show my screen how
female frogs tune out useless noisy
males
ouch yeah so um i
at the end of this little discussion i
will um say what i think about that
headline but
um the research it's based on is
actually quite interesting and here it
is just for a minute it's um
published in current biology it's called
lung mediated auditory contrast
enhancement
improves the signal-to-noise ratio for
communication in
frogs and i'm not going to walk us
through the graphical abstract but i
kind of love that increasingly this is a
thing now that there are graphical
abstracts that accompany research papers
um okay so this paper which came out i
think the paper was this month as well
um basically uh
says that um it it it walks through some
of the some of the background that that
we just walked through that
specifically and they're they're in the
upper midwest of the us i don't remember
uh michigan wisconsin illinois something
um these explosive breeding assemblages
often have several species in them in
part because these these ponds are
limiting
and frogs being frogs and
don't get me started i'm not going to
spend hours talking about all the
reasons that frogs display the way they
do but it's basically
they use sound frogs use used
vocalizations to attract mates
it's the rare frog that uses other
indicators although
i've worked on some of them and
and basically you have distinctions
between species based on uh frequency
both both meanings of the word frequency
actually like the the hertz
um that the call is at and also the
um you know the number of calls per
unit time so um you know maybe
six you know six rings per second as
opposed to two
is one version of frequency as opposed
to i don't even remember what
relative hertz frequencies would be so
i'm not going to give examples i'll just
be way off
um and it turns out this research
basically went looking at uh particular
species hyaluro scenario that's uh
american green tree frogs is the common
name
are effective at dampening environment
and
environmental noise in a particular
frequency so the individuals and they
only looked at females because it's
mostly the females who are listening
to who are making choices based on the
calls of the males
but presumably the males are doing this
too
females can better hear the cause of
their own species and so there's it's
it's called the um
where is it the cocktail party effect
although i didn't write that down i'm
just going to invoke this
it's the cocktail party effect that like
when how how do you know you might lean
into someone not that anyone's been in a
cocktail party recently but
um like that in a noisy environment if
you know that you're trying to hear
someone
wouldn't it be useful to be able to tune
out all the noise right
and when you are in a breeding situation
with a whole bunch of different species
and this
part of the sexual selection on the
species has precisely been
to get the cause into a particular
frequency range in both senses of the
word frequency
um then you may be able to basically
filter out the noise of the other
species
and so as much as i hate that headline
that the atlantic wrote in this case the
males that the females are able to
filter out and i haven't yet told you
how
but but these these researchers did
actually find the females are able
to filter out the males of other species
and they are noisy and they are useless
to them
right it's not males of their own
species that they're filtering it's not
it's not a
subjective judgment that they are
useless they are right
uh comedically incompatible comedically
incompatible
and you know the the authors of this
research paper did not use the word
useless that was an
editorial snark from the atlantic um not
anything about the original research
which is quite good
um it was croak bait oh oh
yes yes yes croak bait okay good um
so from the results of this paper um so
there are also a lot of unique things
about frogs including um they actually
have an additional
um they have an additional tympanum um
effectively so they can hear at a
greater range of frequencies than other
tetrapods which is say all the other
vertebrates that came onto land like us
um or like our ancestors did and they
also have
um connections between parts of their
bodies that we don't have
and so their lungs are actually
yes being used as as gas exchange organs
but also it turns out as dampening
filters so here's just a quote from the
results
inflated lungs created a notch filter
that reduced
tympanic sensitivity in a select range
of sound frequencies from 1400 to 200
hertz
between the spectral peaks of the call
so
again long run so they're they're
basically they've got these
these well the other thing is
interesting here and i didn't
i can't i didn't have time to go back
and and really check this out but um
originally like lungs is a modification
of swim bladders
like we are lungs tetrapod lungs
originally existed
in fishy fish um as swim bladders to
help
mod modulate buoyancy in the water
column and only at the point we came on
to land
and you know some of the early
sarcoptery jeans the lopin fish
like lungfish extant forms that we have
now like lungfish and coelacanths
started to modify that swim bladder
which was no longer needed for buoyancy
in the water column because they weren't
spending time
in the water column anymore as a
organism as an
organ for gas exchange and so here we
have which explains why it is such a
god-awful design
i mean so how is it a god-awful design
okay you make an organism
right that has incredible an organism an
organ
no one organism okay that has incredibly
high needs for gas exchange
right you make an endotherm that's
burning tons and tons of uh
organic molecules to release energy for
heat and
and movement and all of this and so
the throughput of of gases is
the requirements are very high and then
you do it in a blind
sack in which everything that comes in
has to go back out and you couldn't
possibly load the thing with enough
musculature to be able to eject
water if you were to fill those sacks
with water so you have to go your whole
life and never fill those sacks with
water because there's no one doing it
right even hanging them upside down
doesn't really work
um yeah well so uh you know early
tetrapods are not endotherms of course
and amphibians actually have multiple um
organs of gas exchange they breathe
through their skin
as well they breathe they're basically
when you if you just
if you spend time just looking at frogs
you'll see that their throats are always
kind of pulsing and that's actually gas
exchange they're actually breathing by
doing that they're not pulling it in
through their mouth they're actually
doing gas exchange
through the skin under their throat um
but both the
separate evolutions of endothermy in
tetrapods
birds and mammals have have figured out
different ways to basically help out the
lungs
so you know birds have
accessory lungs in various places little
like little
places of gas exchange and then we
mammals have a diaphragm
right so we have you know we have this
thing that was just a transverse septum
separating
our guts from our our pleural and our
pericardial cavities
um north um you know posterior to that
um
and that transfer septum anterior to
that sorry yes
um and that became muscularized and now
we call it the diaphragm and it
basically it helps us
um pull breath but it doesn't it can't
help us get water out of our lungs
in order to make it efficient for you
know
basically every breath you're gonna you
know take in in your lifetime it can't
be effective for the rare case in which
your lungs have
filled with um liquid
but you know it all makes sense if you
think about the fishy fish as you put it
um the fishy fish do gas exchange in a
much more elegant way
than we do right where the um the
oxygenated water
passes through in one direction there's
no need to eject it from a sack
right right um it just passes through in
one well the yeah
the exactly the water passes through the
places of get the capillaries which are
the places of gas exchange are in the
gills
and and the oxygen gets pulled out and
then the you know and
the water then continues back so it's a
natural flow rather than
pulling in the stuff and pushing it back
out which then creates this problem
where you have a tube
in which basically there's an amount of
exchange you're not doing
you know if you think about a snorkel
that was 10 feet long and the fact that
your
lungs you wouldn't be able to get enough
exchange at the tip because you'd just
be constantly breathing back in
the same depleted right air so yeah it's
a bad it's a bad design that we're stuck
with because
initially it was a you know a cool hack
to a a creature that um you know for
which it was a sufficient
addition right but we're now we're now
struck with the stuck with the
consequences and there are
gosh one of one of the favorite lectures
i used to give was on the origin of
tetrapods and just
you know i'd ask students in the
beginning after sort of walking through
some of the some of the fossil evidence
and just being like okay now you're on
land
think about every every system that
needs to be fixed or re-upped or changed
or modified in some way and i'm like i'm
i'm not even going to say the answer
here maybe i'll come back in another
or if we're going to do this i'll post
that at the beginning of an episode and
come back to it near the end so that
people actually have some time to think
about it but
it's not just breathing it's by a lot
right it's not
just oh my god i was breathing water and
now i have to breathe there i you know i
have to do gas exchange in which the
medium that i'm pulling the gas out of
was liquid and now it's gas there's a
whole lot else going on that has to be
solved as you move
from your medium being aqueous as
opposed to gaseous
well i'm looking forward to us having
that conversation at some point in part
because
uh in the time since you most recently
delivered that lecture i'm sure
tetrapods have come a long way we will
learn
all of the developments that have
occurred in that class well we're a
mobile group in part so we managed to
make progress
yes we pretend that we make progress yes
we move ourselves relative to landscapes
at any rate yep
um so um
basically you know the upshot for me of
this of this piece of research which
which i i love that frogs are doing this
i think this is such such a great
such a great um you know huge ish like a
a use of an organ they already have on
board
um they you know they basically lack the
head shape or the technology
for noise cancelling headphones so
they've got noise cancelling lungs
yeah i i think is they lack the
stick-to-itiveness but
for noise-canceling headphones yes um
no no no i don't think so i think you
know you don't have noise castling lungs
do you
no i don't think you do well actually i
was wondering about this so let me let
me understand the explanation yeah they
inflate their lungs and i'm
having the sense that what this does is
it just kind of puts tension on
everything and if you imagine the
tympanum suddenly has more tension on it
it's not going to transmit certain
frequencies is that what's going on
um i i would have to look i can't find
the paper now
um i think it's a little bit more
complicated than that and
it's uh it's a pretty in-depth wow
that's not at all what i'm looking for
um yeah i'm not going to answer that
question because it's it's just there's
there's too much here that i might get
wrong too deeply buried yeah so i just
want to before we
uh leave this topic i just want to point
out the interesting
um the interesting
[Music]
analogous phenomena that we have that we
can tell
in ours is done at the computational
level
right so we can tell that what of ours
is done at the computational the
analogous
process so if you imagine imagine you
know a situation you and i have been in
where we're in uh let's say a tropical
forest
and there's a noise that one of us has
detected somewhere
in in you know tropical forests are very
noisy
places there's a lot of stuff going on
and
the process of saying okay do you hear
that
no well it's kind of a high pitch like
you know gets somebody to tune in to
those frequencies and what this implies
is that your ear was picking those
things up all along
yeah but that your mind was throwing out
the data because of course if you were
processing all of the
stuff going on you'd be overwhelmed by
it and so you throw out most of the data
except for the things that are relevant
to you but somebody can call your
attention to somebody and say shift this
thing
from category irrelevant to category
relevant right
then suddenly your conscious mind hears
it um so that's definitely
done at the level of you know i hesitate
to say computer algorithms but
mind games yeah mind phenomena yes
cognitive phenomena so um i do have a
correction and again i'm not going to
get into all the particulars and i did
not have time to fully familiarize
myself with this article but if you can
show my screen here for a second zack
here is figure 2
um from this article in which they're
showing
the um amplitude um
that is detectable when the lungs are
inflated
they're higher versus deflated so it's
when it's the it's the lungs the frogs
are deflating their lungs to
get the um to to get the dampening of
the noise
it's not when they're inflated but
rather when they're deflated that they
get the effect
okay the lungs are deflated and that
dampens
the noise so maybe it is the
similar mechanism to what i was
proposing but the opposite direction
like
loosening the tension on a drum um
possibly
possibly yeah all right but i mean i
guess it depends which frequency they're
looking
for but yeah okay um
and and just to you know a reminder of
the atlantic's headline before we move
from this topic um they the headline was
how female frogs tune out useless noisy
males
um and i would say you know when i first
saw that before i'd read
either the atlantic article or um or
this paper i thought what the hell are
they doing and i thought okay actually
the males that are being tuned out
are noisy yes and useless to the females
who are tuning them out because they're
the wrong species
but i will say that the use of the word
useless there
is just unnecessary
fashionable at the moment snark against
males in this case male frogs
and the more the atlantic does this the
more likely they're going to become
useless to a lot of us
wait but in many frog species
the term toxic masculinity would apply
by virtue
of compounds in the skin
however yes however in those species
that i'm aware of
in which the frogs in fact do have
alkaloids or other toxins in their skin
that's a lot of them there's no sexual
dimorphism with the cardiotoxicity
so it's equal levels of toxic
masculinity and toxic femininity
which are in fact identical and
therefore it's toxic
frog affinity um well right
but that doesn't mean that we can't hold
the male frogs to a different standard
just because they're not right well i'm
sure the atlantic would yes
i'm sure the atlantic would
[Music]
you